notre carnet de route aujourd'hui nous
avons décidé de l'écrire en bateau
rendez vous donc dans le seul corps des
landes à capbreton
après avoir trouvé un skipper dévoués
qui a bien voulu nous emmener
embarquement capbreton commence comme
cap au large
déjà le parfum de l' aventure une petite
bille ce fait claquer les haubans là-bas
derrière la barre l'océan le large et
une grande page pour vous témoin de
notre carnet de route met la barre à
capbreton c'est tout ça passe ou ça ne
passe pas c'est d'ailleurs le véritable
handicap de support aujourd'hui ça ne
passera pas après un demi-tour tout à
fait réglementaire
il ne nous restera plus qu'à découvrir
le port et ses 800 bateaux mais cap
breton sans son port c'est un marin sans
sa casquette et des marins ici il y en a
toujours su on a d'abord là encore une
filiation historique à assumer nos
ancêtres ont découvert le nouveau monde
peut-être avant christophe colomb en
tout cas l'île de cap breton en
témoignent de leur passage et que
aujourd'hui d'avoir un port de plaisance
à capbreton et une activité de pêche
c'est bien renouer avec la tradition
c'est quelque chose qui nous frappe qui
nous fait plaisir on a un peu
l'impression de perpétuer cette
tradition dans la modernité
l'amérique découverte par les marins
landais et basques au gré des
fluctuations de l'amour
à l'époque ça n'a pas été médiatisée
tant pis aujourd'hui c'est les
américains qui découvre qu'à breton
enfin presque parce que c'est surtout
les allemands qui viennent
les hollandais et les espagnols aussi
mais ils ne représentent que 10 % de la
clientèle d'été une clientèle
essentiellement française qui vient
d'aquitaine c'est moins loin de midi
pyrénées et d'île de france
capbreton liés par un syndicat à
vocation multiple avec seignosse
hossegor la benne et en grèce passe
chaque était de 10000 à 150000 habitants
cinquante mille habitants à capbreton
seulement une fréquentation qui a pour
conséquence un développement économique
dynamique est aujourd'hui cas breton et
traités sur un pied d'égalité avec
deauville et saint tropez pour un plan
d'aménagement touristique est à région
on parle aussi de centre européen de
rééducation pour sportifs de haut
oh ils viendront en voiture car par la
mer c'est encore incertain mais nous
pour notre carnet de route nous
recommencerons demain